e aí
é a minha família
e adora conta piada o grande problema
e aquelas não são engraçadas
e é sério a gente é tão sem graça que eu
não sei como a gente ainda não foi
contratado pelo zorra total
e eu demorei a perceber que eu não tinha
o dna
é para ser engraçado
é mais uma coisa que acontece com
frequência quando alguém faz um
trocadilho ou conta uma piada sem graça
é sempre uma terceira pessoa dizendo
e você tá andando muito com rodrigo
e como
e se ninguém mais pudesse ser sem graça
sem a minha ajuda
é mas eu percebi que isso acontece
porque o meu lado as pessoas se sentirão
à vontade
e elas perdiam o medo da rejeição
e hoje se sentirem ridicularizados
e isso
o associado também
e ao fato de que em comparação comigo o
padrão é muito baixo
é perto de mim até um joão kléber e
assim engraçado né
é mas que eu quero dizer com tudo isso é
que quando a gente se expõe
e para que outra pessoa possa se
divertir o que a gente está dizendo para
essa pessoa o que a gente tá mostrando
e é que ela é importante para nós
o que a gente quer criar uma conexão que
a gente está querendo dar risada junto
é extremamente libertador você aceitar
as suas falhas
o poder dar risada desse mesmo hoje em
dia é algo extremamente valioso
e em 2015 eu comecei a lecionar a
disciplina de anatomia para o curso
recém-aberto de medicina aqui na ufla
bom e uma palavra recorrente nos novos
cursos da área de saúde é a palavra
humanização
oi para mim humanização não é uma
ferramenta
é uma habilidade que você aplica em
determinados momentos do dia
e para mim ela é um processo
e ela é uma identificação e uma
reconstrução do eu interior
é uma das formas a gente fazer isso é
tentar resgatar aquela criança que
existe dentro de cada um de nós
e aí
o utilizando para isso a figura do
palhaço
e é por isso que hoje
e além de contar piada e torturar os
meus alunos
e eu também trabalho
tô fazendo com que eles troquem a
máscara da perfeição
é por ensinares
se alguém já disse
oi e essa é a menor máscara do mundo
e ela esconde o nariz
é mas revela o ser humano
o e ao vesti-la a gente tem que se
despir de toda vaidade
a e do ego
e aí
um dia desses por exemplo eu tava
vestido de palhaço fui atravessar a rua
é uma mulher parou o carro achou que
tava pedindo dinheiro me deu cinco reais
aí eu falei não não eu sou professor
e os olhos dela encheram d'água
e ela abriu a carteira e me deu mais 50
e era gabi a
e o palhaço é um super-herói e o seu
grande puder é justamente abraçar todas
as suas vulnerabilidades as suas falhas
e tudo que ele tem de ridículo
é tudo o que o torna único e transformar
toda essa singularidade em algo
engraçado em algo que vai alegrar o dia
de alguém nos dias de hoje pode parecer
um paradoxo
é mas para a gente se tornar um
super-herói a gente precisa se tornar
cada vez mais humanos mas aí alguém pode
estar pensando a umbelino ou belino você
tá de brincadeira comigo você tá
querendo me dizer que ser vulnerável e
ser ridículo é um super poder até o
aquaman tem um poder melhor do que esse
mas aí eu te pergunto
e quantas pessoas têm a coragem
antes de revelar
a quem ela é completamente seja no seu
círculo de amizade
e no seu trabalho ou mesmo na família
quantas máscaras sociais a gente precisa
usar no dia a dia o nosso perfil nas
redes sociais ele reflete quem nós
realmente somos
o ok nós queremos que os outros pensem
que nós somos e a figura do palhaço
e vem para quebrar tudo isso eu sempre
acreditei que o doutor palhaço é uma
forma da gente trazer essa humanização
e ele já são muito bem representados e
difundidos pelos doutores da alegria e
no final de 2015
e eu me deparei com essa foto do lucas
na época aluno do primeiro semestre de
medicina
ah tá aqui presente
bom então no final da aula eu chamei
para conversar eu percebi que ele veio
meio cabisbaixo meio com medo de ter que
eu vir alguma piada sem graça
e esse é obrigado a rir
e o que seria algo extremamente
inteligente porque eu ainda não tinha
fechado as notas
aí eu falei para ele do projeto ele me
disse que já tinha um treinamento
anterior então a gente montou o grupo de
coordenação
e em fevereiro de 2016 nascia a upa
unidade de pronto a livramento
e o projeto é formado por alunos dos
cursos de medicina nutrição e educação
física da uff
a esses alunos recebem um treinamento
durante seis meses onde recebem palestra
sobre empatia
a morte luto dor biossegurança e também
realizam dinâmicas de interação
e ao final desse período eles também
participam de uma oficina com o
alexandre penha
e aí
o que é um palhaço que atua nos
hospitais de maringá e também em
diversas regiões carentes do mundo
o objetivo desse período é que nos
semestres seguintes eles possam iniciar
as visitas aos hospitais
ah e alguém ainda pode achar estranho
se associar a figura do palhaço com a de
um profissional da saúde
é mas saibam que as maiores qualidades
de um palhaço
e são justamente a capacidade de olhar
nos olhos das pessoas
quer direcionar de forma irrestrita a
sua atenção
é estar atento a todos os detalhes do
ambiente
e quem aqui não gostaria de ser atendido
por um profissional da saúde com essas
características
é uma aluna me relatou
é que quando ela acompanhava a mãe na
quimioterapia ela percebia
é muita frieza e distanciamento de
alguns médicos
e foi isso já fez decidir entrar no
projeto
e para ajudar a mudar essa realidade
e eu tenho grande dificuldade em aceitar
que uma pessoa que escolheu como
profissão o cuidado do próximo
olá seja uma pessoa realmente insensível
e eu acredito que ao longo do trajeto
diante das muitas tragédias e da
incapacidade de lidar com a dor e com a
peda alheia
e esses profissionais como forma de
autoproteção
e acabou se distanciando
o gerando assim botar mento emocional
uma das formas a gente mudar isso tem
que começar lá na graduação
e aí deixa claro para esses alunos que o
diploma não torna ninguém infalível
a figura do palhaço é toda construída
e na ideia de aceitação das suas falhas
mas isso pode parecer uma loucura para o
aluno de medicina que passou anos se
preparando para atingir as melhores
notas
oi e para associar a falha com algo
negativo
é mas eu digo para vocês que loucura é
incentivar essa busca
oi e essa ilusão da perfeição
a loucura é acreditar que uma titulação
acadêmica é sinônimo de infalibilidade
principalmente quando você a tua uma
profissão que lida diariamente
e com a perda
ah e deixa claro as suas limitações
e nós temos muito pouco recurso contra
as doenças
o e nenhum recurso contra a
irreversibilidade do tempo e da morte
é mas o doutor palhaço
e não é uma pessoa dissociada da
realidade ele tem plena consciência da
dor e do sofrimento mas naquele momento
ele quer chamar atenção porque tá bom
e ele quer que a pessoa tenha um período
de alívio mental mas principalmente ele
quer que todos que estão à volta
e se lembrem que ali tem um ser humano e
uma vida deve ser celebrada
em uma das visitas os alunos
e eles entraram no quarto encontrar uma
família cuidando de um senhor estava
bastante confuso e agitado devido ao mal
de alzheimer
a família pediu para que eles cantassem
algumas músicas
o e durante o canto esse senhor foi
ficando mais calmo começou a se lembrar
das letras ea cantar junto com todos
e a família ficou muito emocionada e
agradecida por poder desfrutar de mais
esses momentos de união e da companhia
um do outro
e isso é humanização
olá meus alunos estavam brincando de
super-herói com uma criança que está
constantemente no hospital devido a uma
doença crônica
e me dado momento eles perguntaram para
ele qual é o seu super poder
e o menino respondeu que o único poder
que ele tinha era o de ficar doente
e os alunos ficaram bastante tocados mas
continuaram brincando porque a missão
naquele dia era fazer com que aquele
menino se distraísse da dor
ah e fosse embora para casa um pouco
mais feliz
a minha aluna estava passando em frente
a um quarto e foi convidada a entrar
e por uma senhora que tava pedindo um
abraço
e ela disse que aquilo era o que faltava
para ela ficar boa
e a minha mãe não continua conversando e
perguntou quando ela teria alta
e a senhora respondeu que naquela manhã
ela já tinha recebido alta porque o
corpo tinha sarado
é mas o abraço
eu quero que tava faltando para curar
sua alma
ah mais tarde eu sou aluna me revelou
é que na verdade naquele dia naquele
momento
e quem tinha sido curada
e se dela mesmo
e isso é humanização
é nenhuma criança deveria sofrer o
perder a capacidade de sonhar e brincar
e nenhuma pessoa deveria se sentir
sozinho e nem o idoso deveria sentir
saudade de um abraço é por isso que os
meus alunos estão sempre prontos no
final de semana
e eles deixam de lado a timidez o
cansaço a saudade da família coloca no
cantinho do peito as próprias dores
e vestem o seu nariz e as roupas do
ridículo
e aí
e munidos apenas de sorriso e abraço
e eles estão abertos para semear um
pouco mais de amor no mundo
tô mudando a nossa realidade
e a cada passo a cada tropeço
e a cada sorriso
e na sacola de vocês tem um brinde muito
especial que é o nariz de palhaço peço
que vocês peguem
e eu quero que vocês estejam cientes do
poder que esse nariz tem
e quando usado corretamente
e tem que ler a bula ele tem a
capacidade de resgatar sua criança
interior que vai inundar o seu coração
com doses absurdas de humanidade e amor
ao próximo
a e agora eu quero que vocês busquem lá
no fundo do peito aquela grande dose de
coragem
e coloque o nariz e olha aí nos olhos da
pessoa que está ao seu lado durante 3
segundos esse é o seu batismo como
palhaço
e no final desses três segundos eu quero
que vocês façam a sua melhor careta na
verdade eu sou tão feio que a minha
melhor careta é a minha pior careta
então
e essa sensação que vocês estão sentindo
agora esse misto de vergonha e de
alegria com o sorriso do outro
qual é a sua alma abraçando humanização
não deixe que ela se separem
olá eu sou apenas o orientador nesse
projeto
e eu gostaria que vocês
o que os meus alunos da upa ficassem de
pé
que estão aqui presentes os alunos e
ex-alunos
e não muito obrigado